- Hello, and welcome to
Khan Academy Live SAT.
I'm Eric, I'm an SAT tutor and one of the
SAT experts here at Khan Academy,
and I'm so excited to be with you today,
and over the course of the next few weeks,
as we cover SAT math, reading and writing
with one class a week.
Now before we get into SAT math,
which is our topic for today,
I want to give you a quick
overview of what's coming up,
for each of the next few weeks.
Let's take a look.
So like I mentioned,
today's class is going to cover SAT math,
next week on Tuesday, May 23rd,
at 7:00 pm Eastern, 4:00 pm Pacific,
I'm going to cover SAT writing,
followed by SAT reading, rather,
followed by SAT writing.
And you'll see that all of these classes
will happen at Tuesdays,
at the exact same time,
so if you were able to make it today,
you'll also be able to make it
for the following classes.
And you know, if you can't
make any of these classes,
don't worry, we'll record
all of the classes,
and send out the recordings,
so that you can watch each of the classes,
whenever is most convenient for you.
And so that's sneak
peak at what's coming up
for the next few weeks,
and for today, let's take a look at what
we'll cover within SAT math.
So for today, the first
thing I'm going to cover
is how to avoid careless mistakes,
and the reason I want
to cover this is that,
you know, careless
mistakes are a possibility
for anyone and on any
topic within SAT math.
And so it's great to start
out with, as a foundation.
Next thing I want to cover
is function notation,
and this is another one of
those really common concepts,
that can show up in a
variety of ways in the SAT.
And third, I'll cover graph problems,
graphing table problems on the SAT,
and I'm covering this because not only
do graphs and tables
show up within SAT math,
but in the evidence based
reading and writing sections,
you'll often come across graphs and tables
that you'll be asked to interpret
and relate back to the author's point.
And then last, but not least,
I'll wrap up with a Khan Academy badge,
for attending this class,
and answer any questions at the end,
on anything that I covered for the day.
And so, we've got a lot
of topics to cover today,
so let's dive straight
in, start doing some math,
and doing some practice problems.
So first, how should you
avoid careless mistakes
on the SAT math?
So what I'll share today is one approach
that has really helped me be
more organized and methodical,
and cut down on the number of error,
careless mistakes that I make,
and I've found that a
lot of other students
also find it helpful.
And so the first step I
encourage you to take is,
to read and understand the
question one part at a time.
So when you break things up and annotate,
and underline as you go,
it will help you process
all of the information,
and keep you focused on the question.
Next I encourage you to write out
the steps you need to
take to solve the problem,
so this will prevent you from going
one step too far, or too short.
And so this is really helpful,
and it's almost like a roadmap
for what you want to do
first, second, third and so forth.
Next, you really want
to do the math on paper,
or on the calculator and,
now matter how confident
you might be feeling,
I really discourage you
from doing, from doing this in your head,
as it really ups the chances
that you make a careless mistake.
And so, put it on paper, type
it out on your calculator.
And then last but not least,
mark down the answer in your test booklet,
and so, if you have A, B, C, D like this,
you can circle A, or you can
write out A and block it,
and this is all about making sure that
once you have the right answer,
that answer gets to
your, the bubble sheet.
And so, four steps that I like to follow,
read and understand the question,
second, write out the
steps you need to take,
third, do the math on
paper or on the calculator,
and then finally, mark down
the answer in your testbook.
And so, this process is
one that I try and use,
regardless of what I'm working on,
whether it's quadratic formula,
or right triangle questions,
or function notation problems.
And so, give this process a try,
and what we'll do now is,
instead of just walking
through the concept,
apply this in the context
of real SAT math questions.
And so let's take a look at our first one.
And I'm going to zoom in here,
just to make sure everyone can read it.
So in this first question,
I'm going to read the question first,
so which of the following expressions
is equivalent to the above expression?
And so, it's a pretty
straightforward question,
and so I understand that,
and then I want to figure
out the steps I want to take,
and so this is, you've got,
notice you've got some multiplication,
and you've got some subtraction,
and so I want to do multiply first,
and then I want to do the subtraction.
And so this is some good
Order of Operations,
and if you want a quick refresher on
the Order of Operations,
head on over to Khan Academy,
and do a quick search, but for now,
I'll just rewrite this here,
and start doing some of the math.
Negative five z minus two, minus z,
times three minus z,
and before I go any further,
I want to note that, you know,
it's important for questions like this
to really differentiate
your two and your zs,
so that you don't get them confused.
Because if you do, it really
does change the answer
that you might get.
So if I go ahead and
continue with this problem,
negative five z, minus,
and then what I'm going to do here is,
I'm going to FOIL,
so do some FOIL polynomial multiplication,
and so that stands for
First, Out, Inner, Last.
And so this is FOIL, and so
if I multiply the first terms,
the two times the three
is going to be six.
The outer terms, the
two times the negative z
is going to be minus two z.
The inner terms are going
to be minus three z,
so the negative three times z,
and then I've got the
negative z times negative z,
so that's going to be
a positive z squared.
And so, I still have this negative sign,
but I have done this multiplication,
and now I'm just going to
combine some like terms,
still leave that negative sign out there.
So I've got six minus five z,
plus z squared.
And now I can distribute
this negative sign,
and so if I have this negative five z,
negative times six is just
going to be minus six,
and this negative one
times this negative five z,
is going to be plus five z.
And then this negative
times this plus z squared
is going to lead to negative z squared,
and now again,
I can continue with this
second step of subtraction,
and I've got this negative five z,
and this positive five z,
so these will cancel out,
leaving me with negative
six minus z squared,
which is also the same as
negative z squared minus six.
And so then, I look over here,
and I've got negative z squared minus six,
and so my answer choice is C,
and the last step I do is,
I will mark down C,
and make it very clear,
so there's no chance of making a mistake,
when I carry it over to the bubble sheet.
So that is an example, one example,
of how you can apply this
more organized process
within a question that has a few steps,
and where order matters.
Now, that,
that question, it may have
been straightforward for you,
it might have been more challenging,
but go ahead and do some practice,
and what we'll do next,
is a slightly different problem
with a little bit more information,
where using more organized
process is even more helpful.
So let's take a look.
Okay, so I'm going to zoom
out just a little bit here.
So let's give this question a read.
A distributor ships
DVDs to several stores,
the shipping boxes contain several DVDs,
and their cases, plus a layer of padding
at each end of the boxes.
Okay, the DVD cases and layers of padding
can be arranged neatly inside each box.
Each DVD case is 14 millimeters thick,
and each layer of padding
is 10 millimeters thick.
And the length of the interior
of the box is 132 millimeters.
If d represents the number of DVDs
that the distributor can fit into one box,
with two layers of padding,
which of the following inequalities
best models this situation?
So I don't know about you,
but that was a good bit of information,
and a lot of sentences.
And so what's helpful at this point,
is to break down the
question one part at a time,
and to pull out the relevant information.
And so we have DVDs that
are 14 millimeters thick,
and then we have padding,
so I'm just going to abbreviate pad,
is 10 millimeters thick.
And then we have the length
of the interior of the box,
so the box is going to
be 132 millimeters thick.
And then d, is the number
of DVDs in one box,
and then, one box with
two layers of padding,
and so that's important.
With two layers of padding.
And so now I have all of
the information I need
from the paragraph, and I
can start to process it.
And what's even more helpful
here is to draw a diagram,
so this goes back to figuring out
what steps you need to take,
and also doing a lot on paper.
And so if I start with this,
I know that this box is
132 millimeters thick,
and then I've got two layers of padding,
and we've got padding
at each end of the box,
as you see here.
And so I've got this padding here,
and I've got this padding here,
and that's going to be 10
millimeters and 10 millimeters,
so that makes sense.
And then within this,
I've got a number of DVDs
being put inside, and so
these are all, you know, DVDs,
DVDs, so on, so forth.
And each of these is 14 millimeters,
based on what I have here.
And so now with this
diagram, and these labels,
I know that my one side of the inequality
is going to be 132 millimeters,
since that's the size of the box,
and it all has to fit within the box.
And then I have these, the
padding that I can work with,
and so I've got this, and I've got this.
So that feels like
something I can start with,
and so that is going to be 20,
and then within the box, I've
got 14 millimeter thick DVDs,
since d represents the number of DVDs,
I can write this as 14 d plus 20.
So 14 millimeters thick per DVD,
times the number of DVDs,
plus 20 for the padding,
should be less than or equal to 132.
And so then that is going
to be my final answer, B.
So,
in this example, you saw that,
really breaking down the question,
into each of it's parts,
pulling that information out,
figuring out how you want
to solve the problem,
and then drawing a diagram
and doing it all on paper,
was a good way to keep yourself organized
as you solve the problem,
and ensure that you didn't make
any mistakes along the way.
Now, that's the last careless
mistake focus problem,
but the same process
that we walked through,
I'm also going to apply
in all of the other
sample problems that
we walk through today.
Since, like I mentioned,
it's not just for algebra,
it's not just for word problems,
it can really help you with,
across the SAT math test.
And so next up,
we're going to look at
some function notation,
I'm going to do a quick overview,
and then do some practice
problems together.
Okay, let's take a look.
So first in this function notation recap,
I want to talk about what is a function.
So function notation,
well a function, and I'll
do some abbreviation,
takes in an input, does
some number crunching,
and then creates an output.
And so, you might have seen this written
in your algebra class as f of x,
or as g of x, or h of x,
and in this case, x is
going to be your input,
and then all of the letters,
f, g and h,
are just different ways
of denoting a function.
And so an example of a
function might be f of x,
equals x plus two.
And a few common ways you
might see this on the SAT
is within a table format,
so you might see something like this.
And so for given values of x,
f of x is going to be two, three and four,
and similarly you can
represent this graphically.
So x, for certain values of x,
on the x axis, and then
f of x on the y axis,
if you have zero, one and two,
you have again, along the y axis,
one, two, three, four,
the same thing, the same
function can be represented
as this line, and so for
corresponding values of x,
you have values of f of x.
Now the last thing I want
to give a quick overview of,
is compositions of functions.
So f of g of x, is
another common expression
that you'll see on the SAT math section,
and this might also be written like this,
it all means the same thing though.
And what you want to remember here is,
that you want to solve this first,
by solving the inside,
so this, in this case,
it would be g of x,
and then solving for
the outside components,
which would be f of g of x.
And so this is a quick
overview of function notation,
that should get you started with SAT math.
And so what we're going to do next is,
see what this looks like,
in the context of real SAT math questions.
And what's coming up are four problems,
and so they're two pairs each,
so the first pair, the
first problem in each pair,
I'm going to walk through
and work through together,
but if you feel comfortable,
then in the second question of that pair,
go ahead and, you know, mute me,
and go do the problem more independently,
if you're comfortable.
And then check back in
to see how I did it,
and so, you know, only
if you're comfortable,
otherwise you can watch me
work through it as well.
But like I mentioned, four problems total,
two pairs each, and so let's take a look.
Okay, so I'll zoom in a little bit more,
make sure everyone can see.
And so, the graphs of
the functions f and g
are shown to the left, what is
the value of f of g of zero,
rounded to the nearest whole number?
And so, I know that, and I
want to look at this graph,
and so I've got f, and I've got g,
and all of their corresponding values.
And so the steps I want
to take to solve this,
are to solve for the inside,
and then the outside.
And so I want to solve
for g of zero first,
and then I want to solve
for f of g of zero.
And like I said, this
is kind of my roadmap,
and so I've written out the steps,
and then it just comes down
to following the steps,
so it's easier for me to follow along.
So if I look at g of zero,
what is the value of g, when x is zero.
Well, it looks like I'm just right here,
and so that y value is zero,
and so what I can do is,
substitute in that zero.
So then this, in the place of g of zero,
and so this becomes f of zero.
So when x is zero, what is the value of f?
It's just going to be right there,
at five.
So you've seen now,
one example of function notation
and questions in a graphical form.
And then next question
will be similar to this,
and so if you feel like you
have a good understanding,
go ahead and read the question,
read ahead, work ahead,
and feel free to mute me if you want.
So you can work independently,
and then come back here
to the live stream,
after just a minute, and you'll
see how I worked through it.
So let's look at the next one,
and if you feel comfortable,
go ahead and work ahead.
Okay,
so consider the graphs of the function f,
and the function g shown above.
Which of the following
bet approximates the value
of g of f of three?
Okay, so g of f of three, I've
got another composition here,
now how might I solve this?
So similar to the last question,
and I want to solve the inner
part, and then the outer part.
And so I've got f over
here, I've got g over here,
and so I want to solve for
this is g of f of three.
It just makes it easy,
I'm more used to seeing
it written like that,
so in the function notation question,
if you prefer this way,
or if you prefer this way,
feel free to write it however
is easier for you to interpret.
So I've got f of three, and
I've got g of f of three,
and so f of three,
so when x is three,
what is the value of f?
Well, it looks like I'm right here,
and so I'm going over to six.
And so then I can substitute in this six
in the place of f of three,
and this becomes g of six.
So when x is six, and
now looking at g here,
when x is six, what is the value of f?
Well if I trace, the value of g, rather,
if I trace this up, I head over here,
and that value is going to be five.
And so again, as a final step,
I mark down the right answer,
so that I don't mis-bubble anything,
to my answer sheet.
So you've now seen two graphical examples
of function notation questions on the SAT,
and hopefully, you know,
if you were working independently on that,
you were able to follow along,
and get to the right answer.
But if you want more practice
with that kind of question,
you can also head to Khan Academy
to do that function notation practice.
Now we're going to shift
gears a little bit,
and the next two problems will be in more
of an algebraic context.
And again, these two will be,
I'll work through the first one,
and then, for the second
one, if you feel comfortable,
go ahead and work ahead of me,
and see if you get to the
same answer that I do.
Let's take a look.
Ah yes, and ignore the
big blue highlighting,
I wanted to block out some
of the markings there.
So let's give this question a read,
let g of x equal ax minus five.
Which of the following is
equivalent to g of g of x.
So in this case,
it looks like there's going
to be some substitution.
So substitution going on,
and I'm working now with variables,
instead of graphs,
but I can follow some
of the same processes.
And so this g of g of x, can be simplified
to be g of eight x minus five,
so in place of that g of x,
everywhere I see g of x,
I'm just substituting
this eight x minus five,
and so when I have g
of eight x minus five,
I can further simplify this,
like this.
So eight times eight x minus five,
minus five, so you'll see that, you know,
this can be rewritten
as eight x minus five,
which was g of x.
Just in place of this x,
I've substituted this eight x minus five.
And so now if I solve this,
I get 64 x minus 40, minus five,
and so I've got 64 x minus 45.
And then here I am here,
and that is going to be, answer choice B.
And so in this case,
it was just a series of substitutions,
where I again, am working
from inside to out,
and then solving on paper to avoid making
any careless mistakes.
So we're going to do one more
function notation question,
and if you feel pretty
comfortable with it,
go ahead and work ahead of me.
But if you want to just follow along,
that is completely fine as well,
and then after the function notation,
we're going to move on
to tables and charts.
So let's take a look here,
so let f of x equal x over one over x,
and let g of x equal one over x.
Assuming x does not equal zero,
which of the following is
equivalent to f of g of x?
So f of g of x,
so based on the last
question, and how that worked,
it's probably a safe assumption
that there will be some
more substitution happening.
And so, if I solve this,
in place of this g of x, is the first,
this is kind of solving from the inside.
I can substitute in g of x,
and so this becomes f of one over x,
since this is what g of x equals.
And so if f of one over x,
that means everywhere is see an x,
I want to substitute one over x,
and so, the algebra, there
are a few more variables
happening here, but the
same principle applies,
and so don't worry too much about that.
And so f of x equals, is
up here, x over one over x,
and so what that means is,
I would substitute in place of this x,
I'm substituting one over x,
minus one over, again,
I have another x here,
and I'm going to substitute
another one over x.
Now here again, Order
of Operations matters,
of operations.
And so, I've got one over x,
and I'm going to do this division first,
before I do the subtraction.
And when you're dividing by a fraction,
it's really,
you should be multiplying
by the reciprocal of that.
And so what I've got here is one over x,
minus, and in this case, one times x is x,
x divided by one is x.
One over x, minus x.
And that is going to be
your final answer there,
answer choice D.
So the algebra here,
there are a few more variables
that you had to work with,
but the same principle applied.
And so if you have a good understanding
of function notation,
and some of the basics,
you can really scale it, no matter,
regardless of what equation or what format
the SAT shows the question as.
So that's it for function
notation questions now,
and we're going to change
now to our final topic
of graphs and charts and tables.
And like I mentioned
at the start of class,
this will not only be
relevant for SAT math,
but the strategies and the approach
that I'm going to walk through,
and walk through,
will also apply to SAT
reading and writing passages,
that often have tables and
charts at the end as well.
So let's take a look at
how one way to approach
chart, graph and table questions.
Oh, let me zoom out a little bit there.
So how should you approach
graph and table problems on the SAT math?
Well, it boils down to one sentence,
and this is one approach
that I found to be really helpful
for me and other students,
and that is to read the
problem and understand
the graph or table before you
look at the answer choices.
And I want to emphasize that you want to
leave those answer
choices for the very end,
after you already have good understanding
of the graph and table.
And the reason you do that,
is that these answer choices
can include lots of information,
that might be overwhelming.
That might be overwhelming,
or a lot to process,
it might be distracting,
and it might also lead
you down a wrong path.
So it can sometimes be a rabbit hole
that can sway your interpretation
of the data in front of you.
And so the process I
encourage you to follow,
is to read and understand the
context from the question.
So that will give you good,
kind of background information.
And then, interpret the axes in a graph,
for the row and column labels in a table.
And so with those axes, you
get units with the labels,
you get a lot of information
about what the data means,
to help you interpret.
Finally, or third, rather,
I encourage you to explain what you see
in your own words, and this
a check for understanding,
check for understanding.
And so if you're able to
explain this to yourself,
or pretend that you're
explaining it to a friend,
it's a good check and test
that you understand it enough
that you could explain it to someone else.
And it ensures that you won't be swayed
in the wrong direction by
any of the answer choices.
Then, finally,
you want to reread the question,
and then, and only then,
look at the answer choices.
So to recap, read the problem,
and understand the graph and the table,
and then look at the answer choices,
so that you're not swayed or overwhelmed
by all of the information.
So this might be counterintuitive,
or might not be exactly how you would have
thought about trying
these problems before.
But we're going to give it a try
over the course of some real,
three SAT practice problems,
where you get to see it in practice.
So I encourage you to give it a go,
if this feels good and
comfortable for you,
consider practicing it more,
so that it becomes a habit,
and you're faster on the real SAT.
So let's take a look at a problem.
Okay, I'm going to zoom in,
make sure you can read this.
And so the graph at left in the sm plane
approximates the average mileage, m,
in miles per gallon that
Denise's pickup truck
gets when she drives at a
speed of s miles per hour.
What is the best
interpretation of the maximum
point on the graph?
So,
that makes sense,
and now I want to shift over to the table,
and ignore this, so don't, don't,
pay attention to over here.
And so if I look at the table,
I've got average pickup mileage,
and so the title is helpful,
I've got mileage there, on my y axis,
I've got mileage and miles per gallon.
On the x axis I've got
speed in miles per hour,
okay, so I've got mileage
as it varies by speed.
And so that was that step of
explaining it in your own
words, as it varies by speed.
And if I interpret the graph then,
it looks like as I am going,
as Denise is going, as she
goes faster, and faster,
up until this maximum point here,
her mileage is increasing up to a max
of 18 miles per gallon,
and then it drops off.
So, that makes sense,
and that's kind of my
interpretation of the max point.
And so let's which one of these
answer choices matches that.
So Denise's truck gets a maximum mileage
of 18 miles per gallon,
and so I'll erase these xs,
since they're no longer relevant.
So yeah, that matches what my
interpretation of the graph,
and so, yep, her maximum
mileage per gallon,
is this, is that 18, so that works.
Let's take a look at these
other answer choices,
and see what we find.
So Denise's truck gets a maximum mileage
of 55 miles per gallon.
Well, we just said that
the maximum mileage
is here at 18, and so that 55 is out.
Denise's truck can drive
at a maximum speed of 18 miles per hour.
Well no, we know that
this x axis is speed,
and we've got 70, and you know,
she's still booking it, so, that's out.
And then D, Denise's truck can drive
at a maximum speed of 55 miles per hour.
So that it is also not the case,
since again, we have
this 70 miles per hour,
and so we can go ahead and cross that off.
And so our final answer is going to be A.
And we are good to go.
So that question, you saw what it,
what this process looks like,
where you read the
question, understand it,
and then understand the graph,
before you look at the answer choices,
and are influenced by them.
And so we're going to
look at a slightly more
complex example in the next question.
And again, if you feel comfortable,
go ahead and work ahead, mute me,
and then compare you answer.
But if you want to follow
along, that works as well,
so let's take a look at
another example of this.
Okay, so let's take a look,
the graph at left in the th plane,
shows the function used
to model height, h,
in feet, of the top of a pool toy,
above the surface of the water,
t seconds after the toy has
been thrown towards the surface.
How many seconds after
the toy had been thrown,
did the pool toy resurface?
So how many seconds?
Okay, so in this example,
we can reread that question,
just to better understand.
And then hop over here, if
we still don't understand it,
to see if the graph helps to clarify.
So we've got the th plane,
used to model height in feet,
above the surface of the water,
t seconds after the toy has been thrown.
And the question is,
how many seconds after
the toy had been thrown,
did the pool toy resurface.
So if I look next, if
this is step number one,
step number two is to
understand the graph,
so toy height above the
water after t seconds.
And so on my axes, to understand these,
it says height above the
surface of the water in feet,
so I've got height over here,
and then seconds here, and this is time.
And so I'm throwing an
object, so I'm throwing,
and then based on this,
since this is height above
the surface of the water, toy,
so this is above water,
above water,
since this is the height
above, and it's positive.
And then this is submerged, right,
since,
since I've got these negative
feet markers here on the left.
And then if I,
it feels like I have a good
understanding now of the graph,
I know where the toy is
above water, and below water,
so now I can look back at the question.
And so how many seconds after
the toy had been thrown,
did the pool toy resurface?
And so resurfacing, it
looks like it's going to be,
where, do you have an idea of
where on graph that might be.
So, hopefully you've thrown
in some answers there.
Well, it seems like it's going to be
where it's above this x axis, right,
so that is where, that's almost like,
if I shade this blue,
it almost makes it look
like the top of the pool.
And so where it's popping back up,
is going to be right here,
since this is where the
toy is being thrown,
this is underwater.
And then where it pops back up,
is where it is now positive,
and has some positive height,
and that looks like it's at 1.1 seconds,
since it's right between
the one and the 1.2.
And so then my final answer
there is going to be, C.
So in this question, you
saw a little bit more
complex of a graph,
and you know, the SAT
might have simpler graphs,
it might have even more complex graphs,
but if you really break down
the graph, piece by piece,
axes by title, and all of that.
It will help you understand it,
and making sure you aren't intimidated,
or kind of worried and
overwhelmed and thinking,
oh man, where, I have
no idea what this means.
If you break it down into it's parts,
you can build it back up,
and really strengthen that understanding.
So the final question
I'm going to do today,
is a question on tables,
and so tables are a bit like graphs,
and so a lot of the principles will apply,
but you'll see where
there are some differences
in this practice question.
And again, here, if you feel comfortable,
go ahead and work ahead,
if you want to follow
along, go ahead and do that.
Okay, so I'm just going
to zoom in here for now,
and I'm going to start over here first,
the table second,
and then these answer choices third.
So, an online store's marketing director
uses a web based computer program
to tabulate customer
responses to a survey,
which asks customers
whether their priority
when buying sneakers was comfort,
okay that seems important,
comfort, look or price.
The results are summarized
in the table at left.
Which of the following
claims are supported
by the findings in the table?
Okay, so I've got a survey, about shoes,
and the priorities, so that makes sense,
and now I'm going to hop
over here to number two,
and I've got this sneaker survey.
And I'm going to look now at the rows,
and the column headers
to first ground myself.
And so in the rows,
I've got gender and age,
so male, ages 13 to 34,
male 35 and over,
and so this is exactly like it mentioned,
gender and age.
So this is some demographic information,
and then at the top,
these are the priorities
that are mentioned over here,
when buying sneakers, so
comfort, look or price.
And then I've got my
totals, and my totals,
so then this table, if I state
my understanding of this,
is, you know, these are
customer priorities.
Priorities by gender and age,
since those are the segments in the rows,
by gender and age.
So now with that understanding,
I can finally go over to number three,
the third step there,
and look at each of these statements.
So number one, males 35
and older are more likely
to purchase sneakers based on price,
than how the sneaker looks.
And so I want to look
at males 35 and over,
so males 35 and older are over here,
and it says they're more
likely to purchase on price.
Is price more important than look?
So is p greater than l?
And so I've got price, and looks,
and it does indeed, look
like price is more important
to males 35 and over, than looks.
And so statement number
one is going to be true.
Now I'll zoom out a little bit here,
in case you were here, working ahead.
Statement number two,
males between 13 and 34,
had the highest frequency of responding.
And actually, I'm going
to change colors here,
just to help color code.
So males 13 to 34 had
the highest frequency
of responding to the web based survey.
So now, I'm looking at
another demographic,
so males age 13 to 34 had
the highest frequency,
so in this case, highest
frequency is the operative words,
I'm not looking just at
comfort, look and price,
I'm looking at their totals.
And so that is going to
be there on the table.
Now how might I figure out
if they had the highest
frequency of responding.
What number in the table
would I be comparing this to?
So if you took a moment,
I'll be actually comparing
it to these numbers here.
And so is 140 greater than 61? Yes.
Greater than 89? Yes.
Greater than 27? Yes.
And so that means males
had the most numbers of
responses in this survey,
and so statement number two is supported.
Last, but not least, we've
got statement number three,
so the probability that customer
purchases sneakers, so that
a customer purchases sneakers
based on price is approximately 24%.
And so in this case,
I'm no longer looking at just one segment,
I'm looking at all customers.
And then I'm looking at price.
And so, which elements
of the table might I,
will I need to see if statement
number three is supported?
So if you took a moment,
you might have said, this row here,
and so I want to look at all customers,
since this is just customers,
not male or female, or by age.
And then I want to look at price here,
and so it looks like this
is going to be a key number.
And so the total number of customers
that say price is the most
important thing for them.
Now that's one part of the equation,
but what about the second part?
So how would I know if this is about 24%?
Well, I would look at the
total number of responses,
and so in this case, that's 75 over 317,
and if you do the math, and you know,
punch that number in on the calculator,
that does get you to right about 24%.
And so that is also going to be correct
and supported by the table.
So then my final answer is going to be D,
statements one, two and three.
Now say you were short
on timein this question,
there's actually another way
you might have done this,
through a process of elimination.
So say you checked statement
number one out first,
and you saw that statement
number one was correct,
well then, through a
process of elimination,
A does not have number one in
it, so you know that's out.
B also does not have one
in it, but C and D do,
so you'd still,
you would have gotten it
down to two, at least.
Then, say you were here,
and you confirm that
number two is also correct,
well then, you know that C
does not have number two,
and so you can also cross that out.
And by process of
elimination, get to D as well.
So that's the last
question, practice question,
that I am going to go through for today,
on charts and graphs.
And so that really is
the end of the concepts
and the topics for today,
and so I hope that you
found some of the work
on careless mistakes with SAT math,
and function notation, and
graphs and tables, to be helpful.
Now, to wrap things up in class,
I'm going to give out a badge
for attending the class,
and then take some questions.
So let's take a look at the badges,
and how you will get that,
and then if you have any questions,
go ahead and start typing them
into the YouTube live chat box,
and I'll go ahead and answer
as many as I can, okay.
So for the badge,
you're going to get a badge link
in the YouTube live chat box,
and then once you click on the badge,
you'll need to log into Khan Academy.
And then you'll see a notification
in the top right of the screen.
And so keep an eye out for that,
it'll pop up next to this
little like bell icon,
that's my best interpretation of a bell,
in the top right of your screen.
And then like I mentioned,
now I'm going to take a minute
to go through and answer some questions.
And so, the first question we have is,
around time management
strategies on SAT math.
So, first thing I would
encourage you to do,
is go to Khan Academy, in our
Tips and Strategies sections,
and we have two really good articles
about time management strategies,
not just for SAT math,
but also the reading and writing sections.
Now for SAT math in particular,
what I would encourage you to do is,
one strategy called the
two passes strategy.
And so what you want
to do in the first pass
is go through and answer the questions,
answer as many of the
questions as you can,
but don't spend too much
time on any one question.
And the reason for that is
that all of the questions
on the SAT, on math, reading and writing,
every question is worth
the same amount of points.
So it's an easy question,
it's worth one point,
if it's the hardest
question you've ever seen,
it's still worth one point,
and so investing too much
time in a hard question
really is not worth it.
So in first pass,
go through and answer as
many questions as you can,
while still being careful and effective.
Then in the second pass, you
can prioritize your time,
and what you want to remember,
is that in the SAT math section,
the questions go from easy,
so say you have 10 questions,
or 15 questions in a section,
questions one through five or six,
will be easier, than
questions 11 through 15.
And since these questions are worth
all the same amount of points,
you can prioritize your
time by going through,
and making sure you get the
easy and medium questions,
absolutely right,
since they're all worth
the same amount of points,
before going on to the hard ones.
And so these are few things you might do
to get better at time
management on the SAT math.
And the other thing I would suggest
is just practicing with timed,
with a timer at home,
so that you get a sense for
how fast or how slow you need to go.
So let's see,
okay, so this was good
feedback for the next session.
So can you do more difficult problems,
could you please do some of the hardest
passport to advanced
mathematics questions?
Absolutely, so I can,
maybe in our next class,
have a trickier math question,
to make it a little more challenging,
and so we can do that.
And so next question,
will these questions be on the SAT?
So yes, all of these questions
were example problems taken from
official SAT practice,
taken from official practice and,
which are all real practice questions from
the College Board, that
will show up on the SAT.
And there are harder ones than these,
there are also simpler ones than these,
and so everything that you
see on official SAT practice,
whether through the practice questions,
the timed mini-sections,
or the practice exams,
are all official questions
that have been on the SAT in the past,
and that we've built
in collaboration with the College Board.
Let's see,
we have another one of,
when should you start
studying for the SAT,
so with that, I would really encourage you
to first figure out when
you're going to take the SAT.
So depending on if you're
a junior or a senior,
and if you're thinking
about early admission,
or early decision, you know,
figure what is the right timing
for you to take the SAT.
And then once you know that information,
head to official SAT practice,
and create a personalized
practice schedule.
There, you'll be able to
input your information to say,
I'm taking the SAT in October,
or I'm taking it in August,
and then based on today's date,
and when you're signed up to take the SAT,
we'll then recommend that you study say,
an hour a week, two hours a week,
and you can then create
that customized schedule
to say, I'm going to
study three days a week,
for an hour a week,
since I've got, you
know, some amount of time
before the test, so I
can kind of take it easy.
Or if you're exam is in, you know,
two weeks or three weeks,
you might want to step it up,
but that practice schedule
will really help you
decide how many weeks in advance
you want to start practicing,
and how much to study per week.
I would say, obviously
the more time you have,
and the more leeway your have, the better.
Let's see, so I think,
we won't be able to finish,
okay, so this is a great last question.
What if we are running out of time,
and we know we won't be able to finish,
is it best to guess?
So there is no more
guessing penalty on the SAT,
and so the answer to that question is yes.
If you get a five minute warning,
or realize there is not enough time,
and you've got, you
know 10 questions left,
hopefully that's not the case,
because you did some time
practice, and you feel okay.
But in that case, absolutely guess,
so I don't know what your, you know,
what you want to do if you
want to guess all Bs, all Cs,
or make it random, but you should guess,
there's no penalty for a
wrong answer on the SAT.
So I think that's all
for SAT math for today,
but for next week, we're
going to do SAT reading,
and so that class is again, on Tuesday.
And for the next class,
I would ask you to think about, you know,
when you're on the SAT reading,
and you've narrowed down
the answer choices to,
either B or C, or C or
D, down to the final two,
how should you pick between
those final two answers?
So when it's 50/50, what
approach do you use?
And so that's going to
be one of the things
that we'll tackle next
week with SAT reading,
again, with some strategies and some real,
practice problems that you can do.
And so, that's it for today for SAT math,
but remember to join us next
Tuesday at 7:00 pm Pacific,
4:00 pm, ah,
7:00 pm Eastern, 4:00 Pacific,
for our SAT reading class,
and I hope this helpful,
and best of luck as you
practice for the SAT.